raising finance now a question a
question that we often get asked when
we're teaching raising finance is what's
the difference between good debt and bad
debt so what what would you guys say was
bad debt for let's get bad two out of
the way first well what's bad day give
me some examples bad debt
so we're saying holidays wedding I love
it
are we saying weddings bad debt or just
bad financially all together what okay
so holidays weddings what else guys cars
interesting we'll come back to that
children
do you have any children
you have to speaking from experience
what else bad debt give me some examples
sorry
ties Oh toys I was gonna say I've never
going to set to buy a toy before but ugh
toy toys like wow like material things
that go down in value I'm just gonna
write toys so thanks home improvement
yeah call me love nineties okay that's
whatever this end guys bad death yeah
shopping yeah that kind of bill yes
sorry luxuries yes alright toys
improvements what else store car okay so
we all know we all know what bad days
right it's basically stuff that we kind
of want but we don't we don't really
need yeah this is all bad debt so that
we want that we don't really need and
and the thing is because of this debt
has kind of got on a bit of a bad name
right so when we think of debt we think
it's bad so when I was growing up I was
always taught you know the only thing
one thing one thing you're allowed to go
into debt for and that is a mortgage
outside of that you'd never go into debt
you never get any credit cards you never
get any car loans interest mortgage
everything else you pay for and that was
kind of what I did was growing up so I'd
always save so I'd always buy my cars
out right because I'm saving for
anything like that anything I bought
never ever went to a debt which is good
in a way because it protects you from
this but it's not a very educated way of
sorry smart way of living okay so what's
good
yeah anything I like that now that kind
of will cover everything anything that
puts money in your pocket so I can an
asset that's have two t's no cool so an
asset anything that puts money in your
pocket right so for example if you're
borrowing money it's alright it's really
simple actually I don't know why
everyone gets drawn up about this but if
you're gonna borrow money to use on
something that pays you more than you're
paying to borrow it's kind of just like
free money because you're not even you
know even using your own money so like
if I borrow money from you and I pay you
10% interest back and then I use it to
buy a property which gives me 25%
interest back I'm like quits in and
gaining the appreciation on the property
without actually having to use my own
money and that is exactly what I did
when I was 19 19 and I bought my first
property I actually you're not actually
supposed to do this I didn't really
realize at the time so I was kind of new
to it but I actually got a loan from the
bank and when I knew that it was kind of
like frowned upon and we spoke you know
because it's like a hundred percent
mortgage but I got over from the bank
and they said to me what do you want to
use the money for
I said home improvements I'm improving
my home situation
by buying one alone for the bank and
then I use that for deposit and then the
legal fees mortgage from a different
bank for the rest of it I bought my
first house where I was when I was 19
and the the mortgage sorry yeah the
mortgage that I was paying I think was
like I remember the figures now 199 quid
interest only mortgage and the loan I
was paying had over seven years was 239
and the rent that I was getting was 475
so basically I was making a very very
small amount of money
practically nothing on the actual
property but I got me on the ladder I
was making very small amount of money
and then after seven years I've been six
a few years away the loan that drops off
an hour started making from it but it's
gone up in value since then by about 25
grand
the place is done so in essence I use
absolutely zero memory I totally raised
all the finance I made 25 quid a month
which is not very much and to be fair I
spent some of that buying storage first
then 200 a month but I gained in capital
appreciation so was it great deal great
deal great deal but am I glad that I did
it now first house that was great
I then I thought he's pretty cool and I
was telling my grandma about it who'd
lent me to Samuel previously he told you
that story and she was like and and then
I ended up borrowing some money off her
and and I bought I bought few properties
literally nothing down all from often
borrowing money raising finance and yeah
you look at your grandma thing is right
I don't really believe it I don't
believe in luck you create your own luck
you put yourself in the situations I'm
sure everyone here has got friends
family that I've got money and all I did
was prove that I could be trusted with
the money and I could make money back
for her and and and I could do that and
gain their trust and did it I'm sure
some of you guys in the situation you do
the same thing and some of you wouldn't
it's just a thing and some of you I'm
sure will do the same thing and some of
you won't but that was my first
experience of raising finance but then
even like today I say today but going on
we raced finance for that that was
actually a no-money-down deal believe it
or not because basically what happened
was do you all know the story of that
you do awesome at ok very very quickly
not to bore people that don't know so
story that is we were gonna buy the
castle with 800,000 power at the time we
didn't we didn't have masses of money in
the account right so what we're gonna do
we're gonna put half the money down
ourselves and then we're over half we
were gonna bridge and we bought it at
auction so we had to complete with a
certain deadline to bridging company
we're just messing us around messing us
around but telling us it's gonna be fine
we dare say that any way we would like
get a bit stressed cuz it's 2 days for
the deadline we don't complete we have
to pay agent at that an angel 80,000
pound penalty which would have been a
real pain in the ass so it gets to the
it gets to the two days before the
bridging coming ring us up and say sorry
we've got to do a new survey now this is
gonna take like about another three
weeks and then we'll be good to go I
won't tell you what I said actually I
wasn't happy I wasn't happy I was pretty
mad right so I was talking about you
promised us that we told you is all
should this is the deadline and we were
like crap what we gonna do I raised four
hundred thousand pounds in like two days
which is quite a lot so what we ended up
doing was we because we managed to raise
the fire
by messaging out and giving people just
say hey this what we do this what we're
buying would anyone like to be involved
in this project we had loads of people
coming to us what why do you think that
is brand brand sandals brand right
because Samuel has got a big following
and when he says I've got a deal this is
the deal these the figures people trust
him people like him so it's the same for
you guys I might be on a smaller scale
but if Sam who puts himself out there as
a property investor everyone knows Sam
was doing deals he's documenting his
journey he's sharing his experiences
it's the same as what Apple with my
grandma with me I know that's on a much
smaller scale she saw tied in a deal and
I was doing well I told people about it
and she was like the banker making the
interest off you what can i and people
you know and people see that see see the
value in it for themselves
so yeah personal brand for sure I mean
you got Samuel is like a master like a
personal running and getting out there
and showing people what he's doing and
you know very very least I mean how many
of you have posted saying on Facebook
apart from the video that he kind of
made everyone do posted saying that
you're property investor you at this
training and telling people what you're
doing while you've been here last three
days just watch the Vans okay everyone
let's put your hand up well don't give
my hand
everyone that did and that's okay that's
fine you don't have to but if you want
to create a personal brand you want to
create people that are interesting doing
business if you need to let people know
what you're doing and associating
yourself with Samuel pretty good
training we met one we met a woman the
other day we're looking to do some
marketing business business with her and
she was like oh yeah I've done this with
Grant Cardone
I've done this with Russell Brunson and
all she done was beyond their training
right but we're like okay they must they
must kind of know what they're talking
about cuz they've been on with these
good people Samuels like outside of you
Academy mentoring I've done like his top
level training with him personally it
kind of gives you a level so you
definitely work on your personal brands
for sure okay for sure and then you can
you can get the money to buy this okay
but we all happy with what good debt is
we all happy with good debt okay so
basically anything that's gonna give you
a return on investment that's the key if
you're gonna use the money for something
whether it be a property whether it be
stocks and shares whether it be
education in yourself that's like yeah I
got into debt to do this but now I'm
making this whatever it is anything
that's gonna give you a return on
investment is good day and you guys
should love good debt I'm very very
happy very very happy to get to get into
debt if it's good debt it's free money
how many of you want free money